bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros en esta oportunidad de
reporteros el documental que comenzamos
hace 60 años la mayoría de las colonias
francesas de áfrica subshariana
accedieron a la soberanía internacional
17 países incluidos 14 bajo la
administración francesa adquirieron su
independencia muchos se refieren a 1960
como el año mágico y alaban la
descolonización pacífica y el peso
político que fue ganando el continente
sin embargo la resistencia de argelia
derivó en una cruenta guerra por la
independencia que dejó un millón y medio
de muertos el costo humano y económico
hizo que el entonces presidente de
francia jacques de gaulle replanteará el
proceso de descolonización del resto de
territorios franceses en áfrica
la periodista aflorando que la siguió el
camino que llevaron cuatro líderes de
senegal guinea costa de márfil y
república centroafricana durante la
lucha por la independencia esta es la
historia
[Música]
verano de 1940 el general de gaulle
busca una tierra francesa para asentar
su legitimidad y la encuentra en chad el
gobernador félix v fue el primero en
unirse a la francia libre y en ofrecerle
medios humanos y materiales para
reconquistar francia continental
y
al final de la guerra las potencias
europeas estaban debilitadas y los
vencedores estadounidenses y soviéticos
aceleran la descolonización
[Música]
en brazaville charles de gaulle reconoce
el fuerte tributo pagado por las tropas
africanas los habitantes de las colonias
fueron declarados oficialmente
ciudadanos y liberados del trabajo
forzado
se autorizan asociaciones sindicatos y
partidos políticos durante esos años de
emulación surgieron grandes líderes
africanos como el senegalés seng or el
marfileño fue wayne y el guineano sec
octubre y el ugandés bogan está todos
confrontados al viento de independencia
que sopla sobre el continente
[Música]
leo pulse dancing ahora nace en 1906 en
las costas senegalesas el hombre de
letras crece en una familia severa y
católica minoría en este país de mayoría
musulmana de niño lo confían al padre de
un guau
quien le enseña francés y humanidades
muy rápidamente a este alumno brillante
lo envían a parís para sus estudios
superiores
y la observo sobre todo los franceses
eran muy acogedores en aquella época y
ello facilitó su integración en especial
en el liceo mideplán donde tuvo
compañeros de producción tales como yo
y conoció a msc con quien fundó el
movimiento de la negritud donde levante
la negritud de regreso al país o fue
detectado por la mini güey gran figura
socialista quien lo invita a ingresar en
política cómodo con todas las
poblaciones señor fue elegido diputado
luego crear su propio partido en 1950 el
alumno lo hace mejor que el maestro
senior vence a la mina güey en las
elecciones unos cuantos años más tarde
ingresa al gobierno francés
[Música]
la otra gran figura política que conoce
parís bastante bien es felix hufue buañi
primero profesor luego médico y jefe de
cantón se vuelve uno de los más grandes
cultivadores de costa de marfil
y lo alarga
en 1944 crea un sindicato agrícola para
defender los intereses de los
agricultores africanos solo frente a los
colonos
es percibido como una activista anti
francés peligroso paso 11 indica mesut
apoyado tanto por su sindicato como por
la población que ve en el ambiente
alida
como diputado fundada en 1946 la
agrupación democrática africana afiliada
al partido comunista francés pero cuatro
años más tarde se ve obligado a alejarse
de los comunistas muy reprimidos en las
colonias
en este inicio de guerra fría el
ministro de ultramar me convence fue
wayne para que trabaje con el gobierno
la táctica resulta ganadora la rda se
vuelve la fuerza política principal en
áfrica francesa
[Música]
mucho más joven que los otros líderes
ahmed sékou touré y nace en 1922 en alta
guinea a diferencia de sus homólogos no
accede a estudios superiores por
indisciplina trabajar rápidamente en el
correo postal y en el tesoro en 1946
funda la unión de los sindicatos
confederados de guinea y adelanta
acciones exitosas para los trabajadores
se con touré organiza en especial la
huelga de los 72 días mediante la cual
obtiene el aumento de los salarios
[Música]
se trata de una vuelve importante porque
establecido solidaridad es entre los
trabajadores guineanos entre la ciudad y
la zona ruralidad solidaridad es entre
las mujeres y los hombres creó una
cohesión en el movimiento sindical la
cantidad de afiliados aumentó
exponencialmente aparece claramente como
un joven sindicalista entusiasta de la
rda
[Música]
justamente empieza a liderar la sección
guineana de la rda el partido
democrático guineano a partir de 1956 el
presidente director general ganó todas
las elecciones se cobre se vuelve
ineludible en su país
entre los líderes africanos un perfil
aparte
es de parte de mi banda primer cura
negro en maquillar y de niño fue acogido
por religiosos cuando sus padres fueron
asesinados durante violencias coloniales
muy rápido la iglesia ve en él a un buen
elemento y lo designa candidato a las
legislativas elegido en 1945 bajo la
bandera del partido demócratacristiano
el msp buganda se va a parís donde se
encuentra sol sin embargo se le asigna
una secretaria con la que contrae
matrimonio rápidamente barthélemy vogue
anda se vuelve el padre de tres hijos
con gates móvil y con sitios de
concretamente es considerado como
enclaustrado lo que da lugar a una
campaña mediática horrible que dice el
ritmo con de jets es el cura boca anda
agota su sotana le gusta la mujer blanca
todos estos estereotipos terribles de la
prensa colonial de la época y él asume
es obligado a abandonar el mrc
lo que se transforma en la oportunidad
para él de crear su propio partido en el
mes a mes
[Música]
él me sanó movimiento para la evolución
social de áfrica negra pretende educar a
los su bangueses y entregarles la tierra
explotada por los colonos apoyado por la
élite local buganda es elegido gran
consejero de áfrica ecuatorial francesa
y alcalde de baño
en 1954 la descolonización se acelera
francia perdió en indochina en día bien
fondo mientras que en argelia el frente
de liberación nacional inicia la
insurrección durante cuatro años
francia se hunde en una guerra que no
dice su nombre
[Música]
el 13 de mayo de 1958 en aller
las manifestaciones se transforman en un
golpe de estado militar
la cuarta república se desmorona en
dicho contexto el general de gaulle es
llamado de nuevo al poder desde su
retiro
para retomar el control de la situación
desea una nueva república con un
ejecutivo fuerte también quiere refundar
los lazos que unen a francia continental
con las colonias y a las colonias entre
ellas para reflexionar sobre este
proyecto consulta a felix hufue buañi y
léopold sédar senghor que no tienen la
misma percepción de las cosas
la tesis de singur y otros es que si
queremos existir en el continente
africano tenemos que conformar un estado
federal con efe de claves dos votos como
felix hufue buañi lo rechazan
categóricamente porque costa de marfil
es el territorio más rico y no se trata
de compartir dicha riqueza en beneficio
de los senegaleses o los ciudadanos es u
otros
finalmente el gobierno se queda con el
proyecto de felix hufue buañi
que prevé la autonomía interior de los
territorios africanos
pero bajo la soberanía internacional de
francia
y nosotros los africanos de áfrica negra
contaremos con independencia absoluta en
cuanto a la gestión de nuestros asuntos
sin los inconvenientes de una
independencia nominal ilusoria porque
seguiremos obteniendo de francia
continental una participación económica
técnica cultural y financiera hasta que
podamos contribuir a la prosperidad
general de la comunidad para norris esan
sipe donde a la prosperidad general de
la comunidad
es con este proyecto de comunidad que el
general de gaulle se va de gira durante
el mes de agosto objetivo convencer a
los africanos o que adhieran a esta
nueva asociación con francia continental
y hacerlos votar en el referendo del 28
de septiembre de 1958
en brazaville es acogido por barthélemy
bogando quien en un principio no está a
favor del concepto de comunidad de
bondad y la viejita hablemos de vogue
anda quedó decepcionado con el
nombramiento de eu fue tommy como
ministro en 1958 porque destruye todos
los proyectos panafricano si desea la
balcanización de áfrica
entonces en un principio él no estaba a
favor del sigue empezando porque reclama
la independencia y si lo declaran la
donde posó
finalmente barthélemy vogue anna apoya
al general de gaulle llamándole la
atención sobre el futuro de su país
estamos convencidos de que usted ha
venido hoy para culminar la obra
iniciada durante la conferencia de
brazzaville y comprometerse
definitivamente mediante un compromiso
solemne con una áfrica ecuatorial
francesa en marcha hacia su
independencia pero unida a una francia
independiente e inmortal hoy como en
1940 es de usted que esperemos la
salvación hoy como en 1940 en áfrica
ecuatorial francesa quiere escuchar su
voz hable señor presidente al decir
equívoco responderemos de la misma forma
el 28 de septiembre
lleva de gol viva la república
[Aplausos]
la gira del general fue un triunfo hasta
su llegada a conakry el 25 de agosto de
1958 en el aeropuerto fue recibido por
el hombre fuerte de guinea ahmed sékou
touré fue una acogida grandiosa una
demostración de fuerza de sekú ture no
estoy seguro de que el general de gaulle
se haya dado cuenta en aquella época
todo transcurre bien está impresionado
con la acogida y es durante los
discursos que todo cambia
decimos no de manera categórica a todo
acondicionamiento del régimen colonial y
todo espíritu paternalista
[Aplausos]
el nombre de nuestra asociación poco nos
importa lo que nos importa será el
contenido de nuestra asociación
preferimos la pobreza en libertad que la
riqueza en la esclavitud
la frase quedó en las memorias muy
fuerte al mismo tiempo en su discurso no
exige ruptura bajo idea que el proyecto
de comunidad sea revisado explicando que
es muy importante que esta comunidad sea
fundada con bases nuevas y relaciones
completamente descolonizados este acto
es un momento de ruptura porque de
gaulle se lo toma mal o se pone pálido
él considera que el proyecto
constitucional está decidido que se
practique el referendo zanjará y que no
es necesario revisarlo
y lo digo aquí más fuerte que en otros
lugares que la independencia está a
disposición de guinea
el frío
[Música]
[Aplausos]
puede tomarla el 28 de septiembre
diciendo no a la propuesta que se le
hace en dicho caso garantizó que francia
continental no será un obstáculo asumirá
las consecuencias y su territorio
cobrará como le plazca
en las condiciones que quieran
seguirá la ruta que quiera el muro
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el no a la comunidad franco-africana
ganó el 28 de septiembre en guinea
cuatro días más tarde el 2 de octubre de
1958 guinea proclama su independencia
[Música]
a
es general del gol don ofendido el
general de gaulle dio la orden de
abandonar ya inmediatamente guinea
se lleva todo le dan los archivos son
quemados los bancos vaciados los
policías son desarmados
no quedan ya podía ríe
[Música]
aparte de guinea los 13 otros
territorios de áfrica francesa votan
masivamente por el sí a la comunidad
franco africana en níger el socialista
llevo bakari trato de hacer campaña a
favor de la secesión pero la
administración colonial saboteo las
elecciones para poner en el poder a
hammam y de oria
en áfrica ecuatorial francesa barthélemy
buganda hizo votar a favor del sí para
no aislar su territorio
sabe que la independencia e inmediata
reduciría a van de sar y a polvo del
imperio
pero él tiene grandes ambiciones para su
país
[Música]
su proyecto nace de la idea de mantener
la estructura que representa la áfrica
ecuatorial francesa y deja de crear un
gran centro áfrica que se transforme en
una federación de estados de áfrica
latina cuyo objetivo sea alejar las
varias amenazas para mismo la moneda el
panarabismo el comunismo el peligro
amarillo y todo lo que podía venir de
áfrica los sajones si venía la fe con el
sexo
pero bástele mi banda no contó con el
tiempo para llevar a cabo dicho proyecto
el 29 de marzo de 1959 su avión se
estrelló entre werder a ti y baní
[Música]
demoran dos días encontrando los restos
no hay sobrevivientes los testigos son
ignorados la investigación realizada de
cualquier forma los rumores de atentado
divide en el país y es una consecuencia
dramática encarna a toda la lucha desde
el principio y la cuenta con pocas
personas formadas para garantizar su
sucesión porque no se lo imagino
apenas naciente la república
centroafricana queda huérfana la
división casi 500 ferina
[Aplausos]
[Música]
battle y mi banda tiene derecho a
exigidas de estado en baño desde
entonces es considerado por sus
compatriotas como el padre fundador de
la república centroafricana
[Música]
en 1959 léopold sédar senghor no
renunció a su proyecto de federación
panafricana que emprende con el sudan
francés de movido keita
a la paz
quizás en principio habían concebido una
federación alrededor de ocho territorios
que constituían la áfrica occidental
francesa y el principio era caminar
juntos hacia la independencia en una
federación 71 son allen de palmas en
infecar acción
pero en parís felix hufue buañi no está
de acuerdo para desvaríos del proyecto
de federación incita a la aita vuelta
elda home y níger a conformar con costa
de marfil una asociación más flexible el
consejo de entendimiento sin embargo the
goal acepta la solicitud de sancor y
kate a quienes crean una federación de
malí independiente en el seno de la
comunidad
cuando un niño se vuelve grande y
alcanzado la mayoría asume sus
responsabilidades y decide fundar un
lugar
los padres se conmueven primero y luego
aceptan porque los lazos familiares no
se rompieron el general de gaulle es un
buen padre de familia es por ello que
acepta un mal y independiente
y alegre para más
pero la federación de malí dura tan solo
unos cuantos meses muy rápidamente
dirigentes sudaneses y senegaleses se
disputan cargos claves y se enfrentan en
cuanto al futuro político del país
[Música]
los ciudadanos se soñaban con un estado
unitario en el que no habrían dominado
gracias a su número y su disciplina
nosotros queríamos un estado federal muy
flexible soñaban con concentrar los
poderes federales en las manos de un
solo hombre
nosotros queríamos un régimen
democrático donde los poderes para
colaborar serían compartidos y
equilibrados
[Música]
el divorcio se consuma entre los dos
países y los territorios son separados
definitivamente
el 22
con igualdad
la comunidad deseada por de golf fue
barrida por el viento de independencias
de 1960
entre el 1º de enero y el 31 de
diciembre 17 países de áfrica
subsahariana acceden a la soberanía
internacional 14 de ellos bajo
administración francesa
[Música]
la comunidad franco-africana fue fundada
bajo la noción de adhesión de las élites
y de los pueblos africanos en cuanto a
los dirigentes africanos deseen ir más
allá de ese marco para de gaulle no es
posible renegar se políticamente francia
no tiene elección no se hará una nueva
guerra de argelia senegal en el sudán
francés en níger u otro lado no tiene
sentido
[Música]
no más guerra sin embargo el ejército
francés adelanta una represión feroz en
camerún o desde hace cinco años
[Música]
junto a los líderes y los apoyos de la
upc unión de las poblaciones de camerún
el partido reclama la independencia
rechaza participar en las elecciones
organizadas por los colonos
en la medida que están los perturbadores
gente que tienen proyectos particulares
para su país lo que quiere independencia
real es decir retomar los recursos
mineros naturales la tierra o mejorar
poco a poco todos estos líderes
desaparecen si tú tenido amistad entre
ellos rubén un niño ve abatido por el
ejército francés en 1958 y félix muy
bien envenenado en el exilio por los
servicios secretos franceses dos años
más tarde durante decenios cualquier
mención de sus nombres ha sido prohibida
en camerún aún hoy en día hay pocos
rastros de independentistas cameruneses
en eliminación mediática política y de
física de la memoria pero pues es el
proceso total total
otra persona que incómoda en áfrica
occidental- ahmet sik octubre
tras volverse héroe del anticolonialismo
desde su ruptura con francia insulta a
diestra y siniestra por las ondas al
antiguo colonizador y a sus aliados en
áfrica
hay uno que francia nunca logró eliminar
y no porque no haya tratado se trata de
sekú ture pero estaba protegido en parte
por el bloque soviético
los servicios checos protegieron a sékou
touré contra los intentos de
desestabilización y asesinato por parte
de las autoridades francesas
un fracaso para francia más patente aún
en la medida en que guinea cuenta en ese
momento con una obra revolucionaria la
línea se vuelve un espacio atractivo
para europeos entre ellos los franceses
anticolonialistas convencidos
tercermundistas que exponen al servicio
de guinea de los africanos de otros
territorios de otros países que también
se ponen al servicio de línea acoge
también a víctimas de la parte de tales
como la célebre cantante miriam makeba
ya ha refugiado en estados unidos y
quien llega a guinea con su marido un
militante de los black panthers hay un
entusiasmo internacional por guinea en
ese momento mola
mientras tanto parís debe reinventar sus
relaciones con los 14 nuevos estados
independientes con los que firmó primero
acuerdos bilaterales de cooperación
emerge entonces en concepto francia
áfrica resumido en estas cuantas
palabras
[Música]
de un principio la defensa de la
influencia francesa en áfrica negra
incluso acudiendo a cualquier
estratagema a recurrir a tu locutor
dos hombres estructuran el sistema felix
hufue buañi quien hace de costa de
marfil el corazón de la geopolítica
francesa en áfrica y jacques foccart
ferviente seguidor de gol hombre de
negocios y secretario general del elíseo
tocar cuenta con poder por el hecho de
estar a la derecha del presidente de
golf el rompido en seguida para los
asuntos africanos entonces cuando un
jefe de estado africano francófono
necesita acudir al presidente francés
político
pasa por un cortocircuito llamado
jacques foccart
es él quien manejaba los hilos el
arquitecto de lo que se llama la francia
áfrica
quien conocía todo el engranaje político
y quien hacía al rey la oreja del
presidente de gaulle
si había golpes de estado o revuelo en
general se sospechaba
pero mucho más en general excepciones a
mí
numerosos golpes militares acuden a
áfrica francófona en estos inicios de
independencia todos no son obra de
jacques foccart
[Música]
pero en 1964 cuando el presidente león
guau es destituido por el ejército
japonés las tropas francesas intervienen
para ponerlo de nuevo en el poder
imposible perder a este aliado fiel que
le garantiza a francia vastos recursos
en hidrocarburos
en otros lugares se instalan regímenes
autoritarios en guinea se trata incluso
de una dictadura sangrienta
hay una radicalización del régimen las
autoridades guineanas recurren a
registros arbitrarios a la tortura en
una prisión política tristemente celebre
el campo de bolton estas violencias
políticas dejaron heridas que siguen
abiertas en la sociedad guineana actual
en costa de marfil el presidente fue
bueno
tiene las riendas de su país hasta su
fallecimiento en 1993 país que vuelvo
hacia la cooperación con francia y el
desarrollo económico
mi ambición es que la postería no me
reconozca como el primer presidente de
la república de costa de marfil sino
como el primer campesino de mi época en
costa de marfil
tal como lo dice no se comparte la
pobreza su pa rap se comparte las
riquezas a veces menos pero no me hable
de democracia de democracia
soy yo retrasa el progreso louvre
[Aplausos]
del lado senegalés el presidente señora
abandone el poder en 1980 empujado por
la oposición y el deseo de dedicarse a
la poesía mujer desnuda mujer negra
tanto tu belleza que pasa forma que fijo
en la eternidad antes de que el destino
te reduzca a cenizas
para alimentar las raíces de la vida
[Música]
tres años más tarde léopold sédar
senghor es el primer africano elegido en
la academia francesa se corte en una
relación fuerte con francia desde el
inicio teorizó el mismo la infancia y
más tarde la francofonía de los que es
uno de los voceros en 1962 el señor
interpela al agrónomo francesa de rené
du mont quien establece una observación
no pesimista en su libro áfrica negra
arrancó mal
la respuesta del poeta fue inapelable
áfrica negra arrancó mal lo esencial es
que haya rotado
[Música]
con igualdad tanto
cuando me llega
aquí pasa la página
gracias como siempre por acompañarnos en
reporteros recuerde que puede ver esta
emisión y las anteriores en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom hasta la
próxima semana